hey PB hi honey possum boy not well I'm
exhausted I didn't go to bed until like
5:00 a.m. last night was the video game
awards and it was seriously so much fun
the after-party Skrillex was there it
was great did you enjoy it Jen it was
really good it was a nice show ya know I
feel I feel not not my best I didn't
even drink or stay out late and I don't
do with the dinner do I am oh yeah then
going to dinner at 2:00 a.m. I had the
best grilled cheese ever I can't even
tell you how delicious it was so then I
got home and then we had to pack up
because we're heading out to a surprise
party for Edie and we're gonna like
Arrowhead not Big Bear no right so it's
a little bit closer but a little bit
closer we'll see Matt it was here
JB was here there now and in and out
getting some food we're gonna go to
Starbucks and get food because that's
basically where we eat breakfast lunch
and dinner at all times that's all good
okay struggling over there the baby boys
peeing okay I'm sorry I was covering the
the camera we're shopping now for a
little peace stop we said we weren't
gonna stop oh my goodness he's taking
not know but we could that's true okay
but what do I do with the dog said hey
what's up hello I dip you so bad holy
moly guys look how pretty this is
we just pulled off to the side of the
road to catch a shot careful
hello oh hi its JB are you filming
tonight I'm filming tonight just a
little bit because I'm not feeling well
but this is really pretty okay cool
great looks back in the car
Edie is on his way situation wait what
happened I want to hurt him we made it
but we decided that there's no way that
we can fit everything in here of the
groceries that we got somewhere now
putting all the groceries into the dog
cage let's go let's go let's go let's go
little boys let's go let's go let's go
let's go
so we made the house everything's
awesome it's cold where's Matt and Jenna
we're freezing we have the oven turned
on it's not getting warm yet you get you
pay what did you do to it
nothing just have some great this is
does look at you guys
that should be here in how many minutes
10 oh my no one will be here in 34
minutes Oh buddy Vermette ok cool we've
got some time yeah here's the plan is
almost here
and we're gonna jump off the railing and
we're gonna surprise him you guys ready
the sight line is perfect it's gonna be
great
we're gonna be like from up here no we
don't have any water balloons it's so
cold in this place it feels good I have
two jackets on yeah that's good it's not
cold Oh
alright do we have a countdown or
anything yeah yeah she just takes me
through she says okay
oh my gosh I'm so nervous I'll be
screwed up so bad
oh my god it's not there we went down
the lake house and I'm going oh my god
no that's a real story I tried to get
Elton John tickets but they didn't have
any so I got Olivia newton-john tickets
ready get it back
you ready for bath time come on we're
gonna get you real clean
I am overwhelmed because I just woke up
at nine o'clock and Santino and
Francesca have made us a wonderful
delicious breakfast of pancakes
I haven't had pancakes from Jessica I
don't even know how long I can tell you
this is incredible even an orange juice
and if you want some vodka we've also
got a I got Bloody Marys
I also would like to say that I found at
vlogmas Jenna Emily posted one day of
vlogmas i posting every day it's cool
it's okay from here on yep
I screwed up that's cool I'm into my
pancakes I'll see you guys in a second
the pups are cute Matt looks like Mark
Twain and the other dog looks like Donna
oh my god I don't know you're one of
those people ooh wait dong dongs on
Rachel Nichols and Mark Twain what the
heck is that
wait did you make that across the ball
guys I'm gonna go I've already screwed
up vlogmas I'm really sorry but we're
gonna have fun here
Eden Allison put up Christmas lights
yesterday yeah if their story behind
this perfectly bad that's going on
perfect they sent me a gold medal across
the wall linking designed a little box
brother but you see like something blew
into the Quaker medium burn for like
years yeah that's what do they call it
Christmas ones
I'll see you guys later happy vlogmas I
screwed up already
sorry love you guys I just want to be a
big penguin right now just do that you
can if you can't do it it'll be a great
video I'll send it to you send you the
clip